on a l'impression qu'on avait inventé
l'état pour qu'un jour en cas de
pandémie
ils puissent ils puissent prendre tout
ça toute son ampleur mais oui nous
vivons sur une vieille idée de l'état
qui est de plus en plus fort c'est
l'état de commandement l'état en fait
d'inspiration militaire on y revient
vous en parliez tout à l'heure qui
étaient là pour mettre en ordre la
société d'une manière plus ou moins
autoritaire nous sommes passés dans une
époque complètement différente où l'état
est là pour faire vivre la société alors
ça n'est pas évidemment pas un
totalitarisme au sens où il s'occuperait
de ce que nous avons à penser du détail
de ce que nous faisons mais c'est une
prise en charge totale de la
collectivité douce pas violente on met
quelques amendes aux réfractaires mais
ça va pas très loin et en revanche qui
installe la vie collective tout entière
dans sa dépendance donc lui aussi il
trouve la plénitude de sa fonction nous
pensions que nous étions dans une
période de recul de l'état
c'est tout le thème libéral qui court
depuis une quarantaine d'années selon
lequel il aurait usurpé est beaucoup de
fonctions qui peuvent pas remplir et
qu'il faut donc faire reculer et bien
c'est le contraire
nous nous sommes aperçus que l'état a
progressé profondément dans cette
période libérale au point qu'il est en
mesure de prendre en charge la totalité
de la vie collective
c'est tout à fait extraordinaire parce
que ça contredit intégralement ce que en
gros le la pensée dominante libéral nous
explique depuis des décennies
[Musique]